alors vous l'avez lu partout c'était
écrit dans tous les journaux nos invités
d'aujourd'hui devait être amanda lear
mais apparemment le privé ça marche
guère mieux que le public puisque les
obligations d'enregistrement de la
cinquième chaîne ont retenu amanda loin
de nous alors il fallait trouver une
star une énorme star on a bien réfléchi
on a trouvé
voici aller sapritch
bonjour monsieur vous me chasser au vert
à l'iss la télévision vous aime vous
aimez la télévision oui surtout que je
remplace aujourd'hui une grande star de
la danse du chant amanda lear c'est la
première fois que je remplace une star
voilà les télévisions vous aime vous est
la cousine bette folcoche bientôt marie
besnard il aimait la télévision j'adore
la télévision parce que je n'aime que
les gens qui m'aiment
alors la télévision même beaucoup et moi
j'aime beaucoup la télévision le 12 et
le 19 avril on verra sur tf1 marie
besnard là à la bonne dame de loudun
absalim écrit par paul cher et mis en
scène par de vieux complice yves andré
hubert c'est les mains pour jouer non
pas aux loges avec vous non ce n'est pas
une empoisonneuse c'est la bonne dame de
loudes à vous poser les panneaux 30
ne dites pas ça peut être cher serait
furieux nous pensons qu'elle est
innocente je crois je crois je dis
qu'elle est marie besnard est innocente
ah ben c'est ce qui sort du téléfilm en
tous les cas absolument